♪ ♪
>> Laura: DID MICHELLE OBAMA'S
OFFICE HAD A ROLE IN TRYING THE
JUSSIE SMOLLETT CASE DOWN?
FOLLOW ME HERE.
JUST DAYS AFTER HE REPORTED THE
ALLEGED HATE CRIME TO POLICE AND
THE STATE ATTORNEY KIM FOX TRY
TO PERSUADE LEE SUPERINTENDENT
EDDIE JOHNSON TO TURN
INVESTIGATION OVER TO THE FBI?
THE REQUEST CAME AFTER FOX
RECEIVED THIS TEXT ACCORDING TO
THE SUN-TIMES.
A CHICAGO ATTORNEY AND FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF FOR THE FIRST
LADY MICHELLE OBAMA.
"I WANTED TO GIVE YOU A CALL ON
BEHALF OF JUSSIE SMOLLETT AND
FAMILY WHO I KNOW.
THEY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION.
SHORTLY AFTER THAT A FAMILY
MEMBER REACHED OUT TO FOX HAVING
BEEN GIVEN HER NUMBER BY OBAMA'S
FORMER ASSISTANT.
THEY SENT A REPLY THAT SHE SPOKE
TO THE SUPERINTENDENT AND THAT
SHE WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
LOGISTICS.
THEN THEY ARE APPLIED, OMG, THIS
WOULD BE A HUGE VICTORY
REFERRING TO THE FBI TAKING OVER
THE CASE.
FOX THEN TEXTED, MAKE NO
GUARANTEES BUT I AM TRYING.
THIS IS SO GREAT.
LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT.
THE TOP PROSECUTOR AT THE OFFICE
WHO DECIDED NOT TO PROSECUTE
JUSSIE SMOLLETT WAS ACTIVELY
SEEKING TO HELP THE DEFENDANTS?
THIS WAS ALL SET IN MOTION BY
MICHELLE OBAMA'S FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF.
FOR CHICAGO POLICE UNION IS
CALLING FOR A FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION IN THE HANDLING OF
THE CASE COME HERE NOW IS TO HIM
THE ATTORNEY FOR THE CHICAGO
QUARTER OF POLICE AND THE FORMER
ASSISTANT IN COOK COUNTY AND A
MAN WHO HAS BEEN ON THE CASE
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
BOX 32 IS ANCHOR AND REPORTER.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
YOU ARE HEARING FROM SOURCES
THAT BELIEVE KIM FOX NEVER
ACTUALLY REALLY RECUSED HERSELF.
WHY DO THEY THINK THAT?
>> THIS WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
HANDED DOWN WITHOUT KIM FOX'S
BLESSING.
THERE IS NO WAY THAT THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY WOULD HAVE DONE THIS
WITHOUT HER INVOLVEMENT.
THIS IS HER OFFICE AND THE BIG
QUESTION IS WHY WOULD SHE DO
THIS?
SHE CREATED A DEEP DIVIDE
BETWEEN THE CHICAGO POLICE
DEPARTMENT AT THE MAYOR WAS ON
HIS WAY OUT IN THE STATE'S
ATTORNEY OFFICE.
WHAT DID SHE GAIN OUT OF THIS
AND THAT IS WHY YOUR THEORY IS
NOT THAT FAR-FETCHED.
EITHER ONE OF TWO THINGS
HAPPENED.
SHE DIDN'T THINK SHE WAS GOING
TO WIN THE CASE AND SHE FEARED
THE OPTICS OF LOSING WOULD MAKE
HER LOOK LIKE A MARSHA CLARK,
YOUR YOUNGER VIEWERS MIGHT HAVE
TO GOOGLE THAT.
SHE SECURED SOME KIND OF
POLITICAL FAVOR THAT SHE WILL
COLLECT ON THE ROAD.
IT IS NO SECRET SHE HAS HIGHER
POLITICAL ASPIRATIONS THAN THIS
OFFICE BUT WE WILL NEVER KNOW
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT WHY THEY DID IT.
THEY SAID THIS IS NOT ABNORMAL
AND DEAD ALL THE TIME.
I CAN TELL YOU, THIS IS NOT DONE
ALL THE TIME.
IF I THOUGHT THEY DID NOT
CONTACT THE MAYOR OR THE
SUPERINTENDENT.
WE WENT THEY WERE BLINDSIDED!
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
I HAVE DONE MEDIA STUFF OR 23
YEARS AND I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE TODAY.
I HAVE TO GO TO YOU, YOU HAVE A
MANUAL COMING OUT OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT, THEY WERE
LOADED.
THEY FELT THIS WAS AN UNFAIR
THROWING THIS IN THE PUBLIC
CONSCIOUSNESS WITHOUT SO MUCH AS
A HEADS UP.
HOW COULD THIS POSSIBLY HAPPEN
IF IT WEREN'T FOR SOME OUTSIDE
FORCE COMING IN AND TWEAKING THE
SYSTEM OR NUDGING THE SYSTEM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK IT IS AMAZING THAT EVERY
SINGLE DAY I REPRESENT CHICAGO
POLICE OFFICERS MEN AND WOMEN
AND I AM HUMBLED BY THE
DEDICATION ENCOURAGE THAT YOU
HAVE THEM GO OUT AND DO THE
HEAVY LIFTING IN THIS CITY AND
TO GO RUN TOWARDS THE BULLETS
AND NOT AWAY FROM THEM THAT YOU
HAVE THIS HAPPEN UNDER SOME
THEORY OF DISTORTED JUSTICE.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY CAUSING A LOT
OF ANGST AMONG CHICAGO POLICE
OFFICERS.
>> Laura: THERE MIGHT ACTUALLY
BE CONFLICT WITHIN THE
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE ITSELF.
SOMEONE SIGNED OFF ON THIS
JUSSIE SMOLLETT WORKING AT
OPERATION RAINBOW PUSH AND HAS
COMMUNITY SERVICE.
HE WAS STUFFING ENVELOPES WITH
THEM I GUESS.
HE DID THAT FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS
OR 12 HOURS OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT COME 18 HOURS.
WHATEVER, THAT IS COMMUNITY
SERVICE.
WE ARE TOLD IS SERVICE INCLUDED
STAFFING MEMBERSHIP ENVELOPES
AND WE KNEW IT WASN'T FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD OR A PRO-LIFE
GROUP.
THIS IS WHAT JOE MAGID SAID, THE
ASSISTANT STATE ATTORNEY SAID.
>> IS HE INNOCENT?
>> NO HE IS NOT.
>> ELYSEE TO SAY THAT?
>> WE STAND BEHIND THE CHICAGO
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
INVESTIGATION.
THEY DIDN'T OUTSTANDING JOB.
I DID A GREAT JOB WITH THIS CASE
AND BASED ON THAT WE STAND
BEHIND THEIR INVESTIGATION AND
OUR DECISION TO CHARGE HIM.
>> Laura: LOOKS LIKE HE WAS
PASSING A KIDNEY STONE FARE.
HE DID NOT LOOK HAPPY TO BE
DOING THAT INTERVIEW.
>> HE LOOKS TO BE AN
UNCOMFORTABLE POSITION.
AND I WAS NOTIFIED BY MY SOURCE
AT CHICAGO PD WHO WAS FURIOUS
AND HE SAID I WANTED TO GO DOWN
THERE AND ASKED JUSSIE SMOLLETT
IF HE INTENDS TO REIMBURSE THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR THE NUMBER
OF MAN-HOURS THAT WE PUT INTO
THIS INVESTIGATION.
ORIGINALLY HE SAID THAT THEY DID
IN HIS SERVICE AND WE ASKED WHAT
THAT WAS AND INITIALLY WHEN THEY
CAME OUT THE CONFERENCE THEY
SAID THAT HIS COMMUNITY SERVICE
IMPACT WHEN HE WAS 16 YEARS OLD.
HE RAINBOW PUSH COALITION CAME
LATER ON SO MY QUESTION IS, IF
YOU'VE SET THAT UP BEFORE HAND
BY NOT COME OUT WITH THAT RIGHT
AWAY?
IT ADDED MORE CONFUSION TO ALL
OF THIS AND THAT JUST DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE THEY CARE HOW BIZARRE
THIS THING LOOKS.
>> Laura: BACK TO YOU.
INVESTIGATION INTO KIM FOX THAT
STATE ATTORNEY.
IT HAS TO HAPPEN.
WHAT TRIGGERS THAT AND HOW WOULD
THAT TAKE PLACE AND HE WOULD
HAVE TO GREEN LIGHT THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE COULD GET INVOLVED.
THE CHIEF JUDGE OF THE CIRCUIT
COUNTY COULD GET INVOLVED.
THE FOP HAS BEEN STRUGGLING WITH
THIS ADMINISTRATION SINCE SHE
TOOK OFFICE WITH DECRIMINALIZING
DRUGS AND WE ARE NOT CHARGING
CERTAIN CASES.
PEOPLE CAN DRIVE A CAR NOT BE
CHARGED WITH DRIVING WITH A
LICENSE SUSPENDED.
GOD FORBIDS AND YOU THROW YOUR
HANDS ON IT GOT.
IT IS REALLY INTERESTING AND I
THINK AN INVESTIGATION SHOULD
LOOKED INTO BY AT LEAST THE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES I WOULD
SUPPOSE.
>> Laura: WHAT IS SKI
DOCUMENTS.
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES THAT YOU
WILL GET THIS REPORT?
>> ZERO.
>> NOT ONLY DID THEY DROP THE
CHARGES, THEY SEALED ALL THE
DOCUMENTS.
MY FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT
REQUEST WILL NOT BE RESPONDED
TO.
WE WILL NEVER KNOW ALL OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT CHICAGO POLICE SAY
THAT THEY HAD ON JUSSIE SMOLLET
SMOLLETT.
THEY SAID THAT WAS THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG AND THERE WAS SO
MUCH MORE THAT WE WILL NEVER
SEE.
THAT INFURIATED MAYOR AND YOU
GET A PLEA DEAL.
>> Laura: IT WAS REPORTED THAT
HE WROTE THAT RACIST LETTER TO
HIMSELF.
THAT WAS REPORTED BY MULTIPLE
OUTPUTS.
WHERE THE NIGERIAN BROTHERS?
LET'S FIND THEM.
>> I AM WORKING ON IT.
[LAUGHS]